in the days before selfies this was a
cool selfie you look close you can see
my mustache right there proud of it
I shaved my mustache off once and my
wife didn't like it so there's no
question the mustache stays I'm Chris
Hadfield we're gonna look at some
moments from my life that helped turn me
into Who I am today
that is spaceship Atlantis that's the
nose of a space shuttle you can just
barely see Atlantis written there and
that is my crew this is my first space
flight STS 74 in the fall of 1995 and we
had just come up and docked with the
space station Mir and we had built a
part of Mir and we were only docked for
a few days but I realized hey if we get
the angles right I could ask one of the
MIR crew one of the three people living
on Mir to get a camera and take a
picture while we're docked so we waited
until we came around the world the right
way so the Sun was shining in our window
I spoke to Tomas Reiter and German
cosmonaut onboard the International
Board the the Russian Space Station it
was like okay take a bunch of pictures
and then I went racing back down through
all the tunnels into Atlantis and got
everybody to stick their faces up into
the Sun and it's incredibly bright it's
like sticking your head into an oven
because there's nothing between you and
the Sun but that little pane of glass
right there so it couldn't be more
scorching an amazing human experience in
this picture I think I'm about five
years old and inside a an instant Quaker
Oats box my dad took this picture of me
I've spent most of my life in a box
that's what we call the simulator as an
astronaut we call it the box but just a
few years after that when when I got to
be about nine years old that's when the
very first two people walked in there
that little boy just a few years later
that link between the fantasy of flying
my little rocket ship box and the
reality of three people climbing into a
box and taken it to the moon and two of
them climbing out of it and walking on
the surface it made me believe that
impossible things can happen
and that maybe that's something that I
could even do so when you see your kid
playing in a box let them dream that's
my brother Dave and I leaning against my
dad's Ford at Sarnia Airport my dad was
the very first pilot at Sarnia Airport
he was taking a friend flying and his
friend in the backseat and a little old
two-seat airplane and his friend was
getting sick in the back and my dad was
like I were gonna land so he can throw
up and he saw this Airport under
construction so he put his airplane down
sort of next to the runway with the big
X on it and the manager came out and
said hey you can't land here my dad's oh
look at this guy he's throwing up and
they started talking and the guy offered
him a job because my dad was a brand-new
flight instructor and after my first
spaceflight
they named the airport after me and it's
now Chris Hadfield Airport I decided to
be an astronaut when I was 9 years old
and I had no idea how to be an astronaut
I mean how do you make yourself into an
astronaut but I thought astronauts fly
so I should learn to fly so I joined Air
Cadets at 13 years old I studied
leadership I studied meteorology all
sorts of stuff but then I passed all the
exams and they chose me to to become a
glider pilot I was only 15
this is graduation day I had just
qualified as a military jet pilot
there's a parade you get your wings on
your uniform and it you can almost hear
the sound of the doors opening in front
of you of the choices that are about to
come up as a result of work that you've
done and our very first child had been
born Hellena had given birth to him back
in Ontario she'd moved out to Moose Jaw
that's Kyle a hugely proud day Hellena
is so beautiful in this picture it's a
good day I was a fighter pilot during
the Cold War
regularly the soviets would come into
canadian airspace sometimes they were
just coming through the airspace on the
way down to cuba sometimes they would
come into Canadian airspace to practice
cruise missile launches on North America
I so I was sleeping in an alert facility
up in northern Quebec and the horn would
go off in the middle of the night
great blaring horn and we would race
jump into our Jets we had to be airborne
from dead sleep to airborne in 12
minutes we raced gotten our jets we flew
out and found these two bear bombers
this was the very first f-18 intercept
of a Soviet bear bomber and here on the
left side of the f-18 we had this great
big light that I could turn on with my
baby finger so we came up in the dawn I
threw my light on we could have a good
look at it see whether they have hostile
intent that day we were fully armed but
they didn't have any hostile intent they
were peaceful that day so there I am
flying on Eric's wing trying to hold
this enormous camera and focus and not
banging into the canopy and not crash
into anybody as I'm as I'm trying to get
this picture it was my first role in
combat it was me right at the very edge
where one little mistake one incorrect
judgment could have huge international
consequences we just bumped the two
nations next to each other for a little
while and then we peeled away and they
actually carried on and went down to
Cuba this picture was taken at Edwards
Air Force Base in California where I
went to test pilot school and it's where
I had a chance to not only be an
engineer and be a fighter pilot but
learn to be an engineering test pilot
the most demanding year of my life
I flew 32 different airplanes that year
had to write a huge report about each
one had to do all sorts of testing an
intensely demanding physical and mental
year and that night I won the award as
the top test pilot and it was just so
surreal a real great feeling of proven
reward for a huge amount of work
I was so pleased when I got hired as one
of Canada's new astronauts that I wasn't
the only one with a moustache that's
Dave Williams and he's a bunch of
different things a pilot and a software
engineer but also a medical doctor and
that's Mike McKay who is a robotics
engineer and Julie Payette who was an
electrical engineer and we are Canada's
new astronauts we had had a huge
national competition but finally for the
four of us it came down to the day that
the president of the brand-new Canadian
Space Agency phoned us and said we would
like you to be one of Canada's
astronauts we'd only been astronauts for
like minutes when this picture was taken
oddly enough one of the common questions
is what does an astronaut do between
space flights you know as if we're like
sitting in a waiting room or a lounge or
something somewhere but I was an
astronaut for 21 years
I was only in space for six months so
for twenty and a half years I was
training and preparing and supporting
other space flights I did a bunch of
jobs I was chief of robotics I was
working in payload safety I was chief of
Space Station operations I was NASA's
director in Russia but I was also
someone who worked in Mission Control I
was a Capcom capsule communicator back
when those spaceships were shaped like
capsules and when Houston wants to talk
to a space ship you can't have 50 people
on the radio I was sort of the trusted
agent for the crew on earth and I did
that for 25 shuttle flights in a row and
I was NASA's chief Capcom so I ran that
whole side of things it was the next
best thing to spaceflight when I was a
little kid in the box
the thing I really wanted to do was walk
in space not just fly a spaceship but go
outside and I was lucky enough to be
asked to help build this huge piece of
hardware this enormous robotic arm
called the Canada arm canadarm2 in fact
onto the space station I'd been training
for it for four and a half years
developing all the procedures and
everything to be ready for this day when
I was outside on a spacewalk helping to
build the International
Space Station when suddenly exactly when
this picture was taken one of my eyes
was struck blind and I was like what's
going on and and my hand came up to rub
my eye and of course I'm wearing a
helmet
boink off the helmet is thinking how
stupid is that Here I am an astronaut
you don't even know I can't rub my eye
but that without gravity that tears
didn't drain
they just this irritated eyeball tear
just got bigger and bigger and bigger
until it started dribbling like a tiny
waterfall into my other eye and now both
eyes were contaminated with something
and then I had to stop working because I
couldn't see what I was doing anymore I
called down to Houston and I'd worked in
Mission Control as a Capcom so I knew
what a revelation that was going to be
for them to me to call down and say
Houston hey I've got some problem and
both my eyes are blind what do you want
me to do
and they thought maybe out of my
backpack here where my air purification
equipment was maybe the chemical that
takes the carbon dioxide out of the air
it's called lithium hydroxide maybe that
was getting in my eyes so they said open
your purge valve and right here on the
left hand side of my helmet I could
reach up and turn a little valve and let
my oxygen hiss out into space and at
this moment I am held in place by my
feet on the end of an arm I'm not
touching anything else I'm blind and I'm
listening to as my oxygen is squirting
out into space
and fortunately that fresh oxygen
blowing in on the back of my helmet was
enough to start evaporating the big
balls of tears around my eyes to the
crusty stuff around my eyes as it
evaporated blinkin eventually I could
start to see again I told him I'm okay
shut my valve and then I got back to
work and it turned out to be something
really benign it was just the the the
anti-fog off my visor like a mixture of
soap and oil had gotten into my eye
but since then we've changed the
anti-fog and so we learned from it but
it was it was my very first spacewalk
and a pretty interesting hurdle to have
to cross while trying to do my very
first walk
[Music]
this picture is at Edwards Air Force
Base at the US Air Force test pilot
school it is an extremely difficult year
you can see the pictures of all of the
other graduates and airplanes that have
been through that school and when you're
working really hard and studying really
hard you you want a chance to to relax
and we had parties every week but this
guy in the cowboy hat his name's Rick
husband he was a commander of Columbia
commander Rick husband in 2003 when Rick
and his crew were coming back down
through the atmosphere they'd had damage
during launch and we all knew the
vehicle was damaged but nobody knew how
badly coming back down through the
atmosphere that hole in the left wing
allowed the huge heat and pressure of
the plasma field around the vehicle to
go into the wing and melt the spar and
burn up everything inside the wing the
left wing came off and the vehicle
tumbled and came apart and Rick and all
his crew were killed it was the result
of our own decision making you know we
we knew that his ship was damaged but we
sort of said well we don't know how
badly it's damaged and we really can't
sort of do anything anyway so let's just
assume it's okay and we didn't even ask
them to go outside on a spacewalk to
crawl over the big door of the shuttle
and look around and see how big the hole
in the wing was if we had moved heaven
and earth maybe there would have been a
way to rescue them and a couple years
later when we changed a lot of things
and the next shuttle flew it was
triumphant sort of a way to venerate
Rick and his crew
and every ship that has ever flown in
space since then has been better because
of the sacrifice that Rick made I'm glad
we got a chance to sing together too
this is a soyuz spaceship
it's the third spaceship that i flew
after twice on space shuttles Atlantis
and endeavour this is the workhorse of
taking people to the space station and
back Soyuz it's a Russian word for a
union soviet ski soyuz Soviet Union
because it unifies the earth and the
space station and it's just barely big
enough for three people and it's just a
tiny little capsule you want to make it
as small as possible because that makes
it easier to push into space if you're
claustrophobic this would not be a good
job I mean that's that's business class
on a Soyuz right there that's as good as
it's going to get
I was real lucky to be the like the
pilot or the copilot of the Soyuz and
and it was a great way to get to space
and a real nice tough safe reliable way
to get back to earth this is a still
from a YouTube video
and that guitar is a Larry vay acoustic
guitar parlor guitar made in Vancouver
Canada and it is up on the space station
right now in fact it's been up there
since the summer of 2001 and it's put
there because lots of astronauts are
musicians and we're a long way from home
and it's nice on holidays and a tee at
parties in the evening you know when
you're just trying to be a group of
people to play songs that we all love
and know and my son who was really
helping me with social media my son Evan
said dad you should do a version of
Space Oddity and I was like Space Oddity
you can't cover Bowie you know it's like
covering Bach or covering Supertramp or
something it's not going to happen
and besides Space Oddity is about an
astronaut dying in space I don't want to
sing that I'm living up here but my son
far wiser in these things than I am he
said dad I'll rewrite the words for you
but you should just do it it's it's a
classic tune lots of people want you to
just make a version of it so I in my
little sleeping pod and just did a
little karaoke along with David
listening to him in one ear singing into
the microphone but then Evan my son Wade
back in and said dad it's got to be
video you know you're in space no one's
gonna believe it if you don't have a
video but that's like Evan I'm the
commander of a space ship I'm busy up
here you know I I I can't he said if you
don't do it you will regret it for the
rest of your life okay so a Saturday
afternoon when I was supposed to be
doing something else I set this up and I
I took a camera and I just like velcroed
it to the wall hit record I had a little
pad playing of the nice audio track that
I'd done with em and Joe and I just sang
along with myself and dinner did
floating and it took about I don't know
an hour and a half
floating around different places in the
station sing along with myself here sing
along over there float the guitar down
them the Japanese module here and then
float around and just sing along once
with myself and then I shipped it all
down
control to Major Tom
[Music]
we got permission from Bowie and his
organization who loved the audio track
but on the night before I came home the
video was done and haven't released it
to the world and this video by the time
I landed like 12 hours later had been
seen seven million times and but for me
the best part was that Bowie loved it he
he saw it he said it was you know maybe
the most poignant version of the song
ever done I never got to meet him in
person I wish I had but I'm delighted
that Evan talked me into doing this I'm
proud of how the song came out but for
me the best part was that David Bowie
finally got to fly in space which he'd
always dreamed of I hope you enjoyed
looking at these pictures with me you
should do that sit down and go through
pictures and remind yourself of the
special moments in your life
you